dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser aux deux équations de
Friedman qui sont des équations très
importantes dans l'histoire de la
cosmologie ce sont des équations qui se
basent sur la relativité générale et qui
permettent de trouver l'évolution de
l'Univers la façon dont évolue la taille
de l'univers au cours du temps à partir
des équations d'Einstein alors pour
faire ça on va faire une supposition on
va faire une hypothèse qui est que
l'univers est homogène et autres donc on
peut imaginer l'univers comme une sorte
d'immense toile dans laquelle est
présente un fluide qui est homogène qui
est le même partout et isotrope
c'est-à-dire que la pression est la même
dans toutes les directions et de même la
géométrie de l'univers la géométrie de
l'espace est la même en chaque point et
dans toutes les directions
alors bien sûr dans la réalité l'univers
n'est pas comme ça il y a des galaxies
on a des étoiles on a des planètes qui
tournent autour des étoiles etc mais à
grande échelle tous ces objets sont à
peu près répartis de façon homogène et
donc on a une assez bonne approximation
si on décide de considérer un univers
homogène et autres à l'échelle de
l'univers tout entier et en particulier
on va considérer une grandeur qui peut
évoluer au cours du temps qu'on appelle
le facteur d'échelle petite a de T et
qui vaut par exemple un aujourd'hui et
peut-être deux dans le futur ce qui
voudrait dire que les distances entre
les galaxies ont été multipliées par
deux ou alors 0,5 ce qui veut dire que
les distances entre les galaxies ont été
divisées par deux ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de déduire comment évolue ce
facteur d'échelle en fonction de
différentes situations physiques en
fonction de ce qu'on met dans notre
univers comme fluide alors la vidéo va
être structurée en deux parties dans la
première partie on va faire le calcul
c'est un calcul qui est assez fastidieux
si vous n'avez pas l'habitude de la
relativité générale donc vous pouvez
sauter la première partie et aller
directement à la deuxième partie on va
trouver les équations dans la première
partie et dans la deuxième partie on va
voir ce qu'elle nous disent sur
l'évolution de l'univers en fonction de
différents scénarios qu'on va analyser
bon alors c'est parti commençons par
faire le calcul pour se faire on va
poser la métrique de l'espace-temps qui
permettent d'écrire la géométrie de
l'univers et on va poser une métrique
dans laquelle on sépare le temps de
l'espace donc j'ai qui est la métrique
va être égal à moins DT carré plus la
métrique d'espace qu'on ne va pas
expliciter ici donc on va l'appeler
gamma
ijdxi donc on prend une métrique
spatiale quelconque
et le tout multiplié par a de T au carré
qui est le facteur d'échelle le facteur
important crucial dans notre
démonstration qui peut évoluer au cours
du temps et qui est présent devant la
distance spatiale ce qui indique bien
que lorsque a évolue et bien les
distances entre les points vont évoluer
dans l'espace
alors pour résumer un peu ce qui se
passe ici on a notre blog d'espace-temps
à 4 dimensions et puis on va le
feuilleter en tranches successives comme
un mille-feuille
selon la direction du temps donc on peut
imaginer que le temps c'est une
direction et qu'on va prendre des
tranches perpendiculaires au temps
chacune de ces tranches et une tranche
purement spatiale c'est une tranche
d'espace et sur cette tranche d'espace
les distances entre les points sont
caractérisées par la métrique gamma ij
qui est une métrique purement spatiale
multipliée par ce facteur a alors la
métrique mesure les distances au carré
donc on a mis à au carré
en particulier puisqu'on suppose que
notre univers est homogène et isotrope
la métrique de l'espace gammajj doit
être elle aussi homogène et isotrope
elle doit représenter un espace qui est
le même partout dans toutes les
directions et donc dans ce cas on a que
trois possibilités on a un espace plan
un espace de courbure positive comme une
sphère
et puis un espace de courbure négative
un peu comme une selle de cheval
et donc selon ces différentes courbures
et bien on va voir des comportements de
l'univers différents on a vraiment que
ces trois possibilités puisqu'on veut un
univers qui soit le même partout et donc
en particulier qui a une courbure
identique en chaque point de l'univers
alors on verra par la suite qu'on va
appeler cette courbure grand cas et ici
donc elle vaudrait 0 ici elle serait
positive et ici elle serait négative
bon alors c'est parti ce qu'on va faire
c'est utiliser l'équation d'Einstein qui
nous dit que la courbure de l'univers
exprimée par le tenseur d'Einstein
plus une potentielle énergie sombre une
constante cosmologique lambda
tout ça est relié au contenu de
l'univers par une constante 8 pi g fois
le tenseur énergie impulsion qui
correspond au contenu de l'univers à ce
fluide qui remplit l'univers alors ici
on aurait normalement divisé par C4 mais
je pose que la vitesse de la lumière
vaut 1 c'est simplement un choix d'unité
qui va nous arranger pour que les
calculs soient un peu plus simple
bon alors c'est parti pour faire ce
calcul il va nous falloir déterminer le
tenseur de Richie et la courbure
scalaire donc là si vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de la relativité générale ça
peut être un peu compliqué mais l'idée
c'est vraiment qu'il s'agit d'une
méthode brute là on va faire le calcul
de la façon la plus brute possible donc
c'est un peu long un peu fastidieux mais
c'est tout bête et méchant c'est assez
automatique et puis on va voir ce que ça
nous donne comme résultat donc vraiment
les équations de Friedman c'est ce qui
sort de ça ce qui sort de l'équation
d'Einstein lorsqu'on utilise une
métrique de cette forme là
alors c'est parti déjà on va écrire nos
termes de la métrique on a le terme
temporel j'ai été qui vaut simplement -1
ici on a aucun terme croisé entre le
temps et l'espace puisqu'on a séparé le
temps de l'espace on a feuilleté notre
espace-temps de façon perpendiculaire au
temps les autres termes de la métrique
qui sont non nuls sont tous des termes
d'espace et je vais noter les
coordonnées d'espace avec des indices
latin
et si donc on a ce terme-là de métrique
a de T au carré fois gamma ij la
métrique spatiale donc vous voyez que la
métrique spatiale ici est reliée à la
métrique spatio-temporelle sur les
tranches d'espace par ce facteur
d'échelle à deux t au carré alors
maintenant ce qu'on va vouloir faire
c'est calculer les symboles de
Christopher les symboles de Christophel
ils sont basés sur les dérivés de la
métrique donc on va calculer les dérivés
la dérivée de -1 c'est une constante
donc ça vaut 0 et ici on a deux dérivés
on a la dérivée par rapport au temps
qui vaut 2 a à point gammaj alors à
partir de maintenant je vais plus écrire
les parenthèses pour indiquer que a
dépend de T ce sera implicite et puis le
point ici représentera la dérivée par
rapport au temps t
voilà et puis la métrique spatiale ne
dépend pas du temps donc on n'a pas de
dérivé sur elle et d'autre part on peut
dériver par rapport à une coordonnée
d'espace K a ne dépend pas de cette
coordonnée là et on a simplement adopté
au carré voilà dérivée de Gama ij par
rapport à K
bon alors maintenant on peut calculer
nos symboles de Christopher on va avoir
le symbole gamma
TIJ puisqu'on voit ici qu'on a une
dérivée qui fait intervenir ijt on peut
avoir aussi i en haut et puis t en bas
avec J
et on peut enfin avoir gamma IJK un
symbole purement spatial alors
commençons par calculer celui-là on va
utiliser la définition des symboles de
Christopher le symbole de Christopher
c'est un demi de l'inverse de la
métrique appliqué à l'indice qui est en
haut
fois un indice quelconque sur lequel on
somme et puis ensuite les dérivés donc
ici on aura le premier indice i fois
l'indice sur lequel on somme lambda
dérivé par rapport à J plus la même
chose en intervertit donc j lambda
dérivé par rapport à Ali moins j'ai
appliqué à ces deux indices
IG dérivé par rapport à lambda
ça c'est la définition des symboles de
Christopher
mais alors ici on peut simplifier un peu
tout ça il nous faut l'inverse de la
métrique et bien puisque le temps et
l'espace sont distincts on a en fait une
matrice ici qui est diagonale entre un
bloc spatial et puis le bloc du temps
donc on a GTT
et puis j'ai inverse ça va être
l'inverse de ça 1 sur a au carré fois
l'inverse de cette matrice gamma donc
gamma ij voilà
et si on précise toujours pas quelle est
la forme de cette métrique on verra que
ça n'a pas vraiment d'importance
donc et bien remplaçons on a un demi
ici j'ai été lambda lambda doit
forcément valoir t puisque c'est le seul
terme non nul ici
donc on va avoir GTT qui vaut - 1 ça
nous donne à moins
lambda voté donc ici on va avoir quelque
chose de la forme j'ai été virgule j ici
j'ai JT et ici j'ai ij,t les seuls
termes qui vont être non nuls c'est
quand on dérive par rapport au temps
donc ce terme-là et ce terme-là sont
nuls on n'a pas de terme croisé dans la
métrique et donc il nous reste moins
donc ça ne redonne un signe plus GI
dérivé par rapport au temps et c'est
ceci donc on a deux a à point gamma IJ
le 2 et le 1/2 s'annule et on a trouvé
notre premier symbole de Christopher
voilà on va faire la même chose pour
gamma itj cette fois-ci donc on va voir
un demi de G i lambda cette fois-ci
alors lambda va forcément être un indice
d'espace ça peut pas être le temps
puisqu'on n'a pas de terme croisé
donc on peut tout de suite le remplacer
par un indice latin qui va représenter
uniquement les trois dimensions de
l'espace et ensuite dans la parenthèse
on va avoir j'ai
tkj ça ça disparaît puisque c'est un
terme croisé
ensuite ce terme-là ça va nous donner g
JK
celui-là ne disparaît pas
moi j'ai
tjk et celui-là disparaît c'est aussi un
terme croisé
donc en fin de compte on a uniquement ça
ça va nous donner un demi
alors le terme de la métrique inverse
gika et bien ça va être 1 sur A2 fois
et puis j'ai JK ça va être ça lorsqu'on
remplace ij par JK donc ça nous donne 2A
qui va s'annuler ici pour donner un sur
A
fois à point
fois gamma ij on a remplacé par JK donc
fois gamma JK alors ici on peut voir
qu'on a une contraction de la métrique
avec l'indice k ici la contraction de la
métrique et bien ça donne le symbole de
chroniqueur IJ
donc voilà la forme que prend notre
deuxième symbole de Christopher
pour finir on va calculer ce dernier
symbole de Christopher là et en fait on
va voir tout de suite qu'on ne peut
avoir qu'un indice spatial ici encore
une fois K et donc ici dans toutes les
dérivées tous les termes ici on va avoir
que des indices d'espace ce qui veut
dire que ce symbole de Christopher et
bien ça va être exactement le même que
le symbole de Christopher associé à la
matrice gamma associée à la métrique
purement spatiale IJK alors on pourrait
se dire qu'on a ces termes a² qui
rentrent ici mais en réalité sont
annulés par le 1 sur a² qui est dans la
métrique inverse ici et ces symboles de
Christopher et bien on n'a pas besoin de
les calculer on ne les connaît pas
puisqu'on ne connaît pas l'expression de
la métrique d'espace
bon très bien et bien à partir de là on
va pouvoir calculer le tenseur de
Riemann et ensuite le tenseur de Ricci
alors ce qui nous intéresse c'est le
tenseur de Richie donc on va commencer
par la composante r tt on sait qu'il
s'agit de la contraction du tenseur de
Riemann donc on va avoir ri
ti t on contracte uniquement sur des
indices d'espace puisqu'en fait si on
avait l'indice temporelle ici puisque le
tenseur est antisymétrique on a deux
indices identiques donc ça vaudrait 0
alors rit on va appliquer la définition
du tenseur de Riemann encore donné ça
nous donne gamma i t t dérivé par
rapport à i moins gamma i t I dérivé par
rapport à T ici on voit qu'on a aucun
symbole de Christopher avec deux fois
l'indice temporelle donc on peut tout de
suite supprimer ce premier terme
ensuite on va voir les contractions donc
plus gamma de II lambda gamma lambda tt
pareil ce terme on a deux indices
temporels alors qu'ici on a aucun
symbole qui fait intervenir deux indices
temporels donc ce terme s'annule et
enfin moins gamma it lambda gamma lambda
it alors ici le lambda doit forcément
être spatial puisque sinon on aurait
deux indices temporels et ça vaudrait 0
donc on va remplacer tout de suite ce
lambda par un J
voilà bon maintenant on peut faire notre
calcul alors il faut d'abord dériver ce
symbole de Christopher c'est la dérivée
de celui-ci par rapport au temps et
lorsqu'on a remplacé j pari alors
lorsqu'on remplace J par I on a un
symbole de Christophe Feld qui est
contracté avec lui-même c'est la trace
de la matrice identité trois par trois
puisqu'on est sur des indices d'espace
et donc ça donne simplement trois
donc on va avoir moins 3
fois la dérivée par rapport au temps de
ça ce qui donne à points sur a moins à
Point Carré sur un carré
et puis ensuite on va avoir moins ce
produit donc gamma itj c'est exactement
ça donc on a moins à point sur a Delta
IJ
et puis gamma JIT bien c'est exactement
la même chose mais lorsqu'on a inversé J
et i donc on va avoir à Poincaré sur a²
et puis Delta Ji encore une fois ici on
a deux symboles de chroniqueurs qui sont
contractés donc ça fait pareil que Delta
II
et là on a la trace comme tout à l'heure
donc ça nous donne un facteur 3
et en fait ce terme va simplement venir
annuler ce terme là donc on se retrouve
à la fin
avec -3 à points sur A
ça c'est le terme temporel du tenseur de
courbure de Richie
bon et bien maintenant on va calculer le
terme r ti qui fait intervenir une
coordonnée d'espace et la coordonnée du
temps alors pour ça on va contracter
selon tous les indices possibles lambda
t lambda I
ici lambda encore une fois ne peut pas
être un indice temporel sinon on aurait
deux fois le temps et ça vaudrait 0 donc
notre lambda doit forcément être
spatiale
on va réécrire la définition
et bien on voit très rapidement que dans
notre dans notre tableau des symboles de
Christopher il n'y a que ce terme-là et
ce terme-là qui peuvent dépendre de
l'espace puisqu'il y a que la métrique
gamma hygi qui dépend de l'espace en
particulier ce terme-là n'a aucune
dérivée spatiale ni dépend pas de
l'espace il dépend que du temps avec ce
terme-là donc cette dérivée ici qui est
la dérivée de ce symbole de Christopher
par rapport à l'espace elle vaut 0
cette dérivée c'est exactement la même
chose elle vaut 0 aussi et puis ici si
vous regardez bien le lambda doit
forcément être spatial sinon on aurait
deux fois l'indice temporel ici
donc on peut mettre un petit cas à la
place
le lambda ici même chose donc ça doit
être forcément un indice spatial petit K
et on obtient gamma JJK ça va nous
donner il y a Mathilde JJK le symbole
purement spatial fois gamma k ti donc
c'est ce terme-là donc on va avoir à
point sur a fois delta de Ki
ici le delta de Ki ça va donc remplacer
K par I donc on se retrouve avec Ji
moins gamma Jik
gamma ktj donc encore une fois on a ce
terme là à point sur a Delta KJ le cas
doit donc être remplacé par J
et puisque les symboles de Christophel
sont symétriques en bas sur les deux
indices bien en fait ces deux termes
sont les mêmes et on obtient 0
on aurait pu s'en douter notre tenseur
de Richie n'a donc aucun terme croisé
entre le temps et l'espace
bon et bien il nous reste seulement un
terme à calculer c'est le terme purement
spatial IJ
alors c'est le terme le plus compliqué
ça tombe bien pour se faire il faut
contracter par rapport à tous les
indices possibles
lambda i lambda j alors on va séparer
les contractions par rapport aux indices
temporels et par rapport aux indices
spatiaux donc on a d'abord l'indice
temporel
rtitj et ensuite les trois indices
d'espace RK
[Musique]
donc là il va falloir calculer deux
termes du tenseur de Riemann alors c'est
parti pour le premier terme on a gamma
tij.t - gamma
tit virgule g celui-ci disparaît
puisqu'on a deux fois t plus gamma tt
lambda gamma lambda ij pareil celui-ci
disparaît on a deux fois t
- gamma
TJ lambda gamma lambda it
ensuite on ajoute ce deuxième terme donc
on obtient plus
gamma K
ij.k - gamma
kikiri plus gamma
lambda I J moins gamma
KJ lambda gamma lambda
IKK bon c'est assez long mais en réalité
ce qu'on peut identifier c'est le
tenseur de Ricci qui est associé à ces
connexions là c'est à dire le tenseur de
Richie purement spatial le tenseur de
Ricci qui ne s'intéresse qu'a qu'aux
tranche d'espace pour ça il faut
identifier lesquels de ces termes ne
font intervenir que des indices d'espace
pour obtenir ces termes et bien on peut
scinder ces deux sommes lorsque lambda
est un indice d'espace et lorsque lambda
est l'indice temporel
donc on a soit que lambda est l'indice
temporel
soit donc je vais ressemer la même chose
soit lambda est un indice d'espace que
je vais appeler l donc je vais écrire l
ici
alors maintenant si on regarde bien on
peut identifier quels sont les termes
qui ne font intervenir que des indices
d'espace on a celui là on a celui là ici
on a du temps ici on a du temps ici on a
celui là et puis on a celui-là et en
fait et bien on retrouve bien le tenseur
de Riemann encore donné purement
spatiale donc on va obtenir ce terme-là
gamma t ijt
se termine là
gamma TJ lambda gamma lambda it
c'est de termes si
+ le tenseur de Riemann spatial que je
vais noter air tild appliqué à
kik J et en fait ça on voit que c'est la
contraction et donc c'est directement le
tenseur de Ricci en I et G
c'est assez logique la composante du
tenseur de Richie spatio-temporel IG et
bien elle contient la composante du
tenseur de Richie spatial en IJ
avec ces termes additionnels qui
correspondent au croisement entre le
temps et l'espace puisque si on y
réfléchit au cours du temps lorsque
l'espace change de forme s'il change de
taille et bien ça peut créer une
courbure dans l'espace-temps
voilà alors maintenant calculons ces
termes ici gamma tij.t c'est ce premier
terme dérivé par rapport au temps donc
on a a à point ça va donner à Poincaré
plus a à points
le tout facteur de gamaji
ensuite on a ce terme-là donc on a TJ
lambda lambda doit forcément être
spatial sinon on aurait deux indices
temporel
donc on a T JK c'est encore une fois
celui là
donc a à point gammagique K
fois gamma kit
kit on est dans cette situation là donc
c'est à point sur a fois le delta
chroniqueur donc à point sur a on va
obtenir à Point Carré
fois un delta de chroniqueur entre K et
i donc on peut directement remplacer K
par I et puisque la métrique est
symétrique on peut écrire un gamma IJ
donc on voit ici que ce terme va annuler
notre premier terme
on a fait ces deux termes-là il reste
ces deux termes là donc on a plus gamma
KT donc là on est dans cette situation
là puisqu'on a K et k en haut et en bas
donc on la trace du tenseur de
chroniqueur donc ça va nous donner trois
et ensuite on a gamma t ij donc là c'est
aaj
et enfin on a moins gamma KJT donc on
est dans cette situation là
fois gamma tikk on est dans cette
situation là
et encore une fois ici on a chroniqueur
KJ donc on peut écrire gamma IJ
on a plus 3 à 2 moins à point 2 donc ça
nous donne plus 2 à 2
il faut pas oublier le tenseur de Richie
spatial et donc finalement on peut
regrouper tous ces termes et on obtient
à à point point plus 2 à point 2 le tout
facteur de la Metrix spatiale gamma ij +
le tenseur de courbure spatial
alors je vais faire un peu de nettoyage
pour qu'on y voit plus clair
voilà et pour finir ce qu'on veut et
bien on a ce r menu il nous faut cette
courbure scalaire grandaire alors la
courbure scalaire c'est la contraction
du tenseur de Richie en utilisant la
métrique inverse on a R qui vaut j'ai
munu r menu
et donc pour faire ça et bien on va
simplement prendre GTT RTT donc on a
moins 1 fois ceci donc ça donne 3 à
points sur A
plus gig donc 1 sur A2
fois l'inverse de la matrice
de la métrique spatiale j fois tout ça
ce qui nous donne RIJ
plus alors je vais répéter ce facteur
ici plus 1 sur A2 gamma ij
Gama IJ
et à apprendre plus de à point d'eau
alors on arrive quelque part ici les
deux métriques se contractent ça donne
le nombre de dimensions on s'intéresse à
la métrique gamma qui est une métrique
purement spatiale donc on a trois
dimensions
ce premier terme c'est le même qu'ici
donc en fait ça va nous donner un deux
ici
qu'on peut factoriser devant ça nous
donne 6
bon et alors maintenant qu'en est-il de
ce terme là
on va utiliser l'hypothèse que notre
espace est homogène et autres en
particulier la courbure doit être la
même partout et dans toutes les
directions ce que ça veut dire c'est que
le tenseur de Ricci spatial RIJ va être
tout simplement égale à une constante
qu'on va noter deux cas le cas ici c'est
justement la courbure qui intervenait
dans mes dessins au dessus fois la
métrique gamma ij alors pourquoi et bien
tout simplement parce que comme ça
lorsqu'on se place dans une base
orthonormée le tenseur de Richie vaut
simplement deux cas de cas de cas c'est
la matrice identité fois une constante
ce qui nous dit bien que la courbure est
isotrope est la même dans toutes les
directions et puis elle est la même à
tous les points de l'espace puisque ce
deux cas ici ne dépend d'aucune variable
lorsqu'on postule ceci et bien on voit
que ici on obtient Yama ij fois 2K gamma
ij on a la contraction de gamma avec
lui-même c'est la métrique contractée
avec elle-même et ça ça nous donne le
nombre de dimensions donc 3 et donc ici
on obtient 6 x 4 donc ceci on peut le
remplacer
par 6k sur A2 et en fait on voit qu'on
peut le rentrer dans cette parenthèse
bon et alors maintenant on a obtenu tous
les ingrédients qui nous permettent
d'exprimer l'équation d'Einstein on va
voir deux équations l'équation
temporelle lorsqu'on prend mieux égal T
et puis l'équation spatiale lorsqu'on
prend mieux égale IG des coordonnées
spatiales alors commençons par
l'équation temporelle
ici on va avoir RTT donc il fait - 3 à
points sur A
moins un demi de r j'ai menu alors j'ai
TTC -1 donc on va avoir plus un demi de
r un demi de tout ça donc le 6 se
transforme en 3
plus lambda fois Gemini GTT
la composante temporelle du tenseur
Energien
maintenant pour ce qui est des
composantes spatiales et bien on va
avoir RIJ et tout ça
donc r tild ij on a vu que ce RCT DJ
c'est deux cas gamai j donc je peux
l'écrire directement deux cas gammaïji
plus
a à point point plus de à point 2 bien
IJ
- 1/2 de r g menu alors ici c'est GI
donc ça va être a² = J
donc on va avoir moins un demi de a²
gamma IJ
fois r ce qui vaut 6 sur a² donc ce qui
va donner en multipliant par ça 3
facteur de
k+a à point point plus à point 2
plus lambda GI donc plus lambda a² GAM I
J
est égal à 8 piges TIJ
et voilà nos deux équations de Friedman
alors elles sont très complexes on va
pouvoir les simplifier en écrivant la
forme du tenseur énergie impulsion
puisqu'on a aussi l'hypothèse que le
fluide que contient l'univers et lui
aussi homogène et autres et dans le cas
d'un fluide homogène et autres on va
avoir simplement un tenseur énergie
impulsion tenue qui va s'écrire comme
row + P
u
+ P g menu
alors gros c'est la densité d'énergie
c'est la densité de notre fluide
P c'est sa pression
et puis u c'est sa vitesse
spatio-temporelle c'est un vecteur c'est
spatio-temporel
et alors l'idée c'est qu'on va prendre
un fluide qui est immobile donc
u en fait va être un vecteur qui vaut 1
0 0 0
alors le 1 ici on vérifie bien que la
vitesse soit normée et effectivement
c'est bien normal puisque la composante
temporelle de la métrique est normée on
a bien -1 de vendre des TK2
donc lorsqu'on prend ça et bien on voit
que ce humu unu va être nul sauf lorsque
on prend MU et nu = t ce qui veut dire
que pour la composante temporelle du
tenseur énergie impulsion on va avoir
repousser
plus P GTT qui vaut - 1 donc moins P
donc on va avoir simplement la densité
du fluide
et pour toutes les autres composantes et
en particulier pour les composantes
spatiales qui nous intéressent ici et
bien on va avoir aucun terme ici
seulement P x la métrique spatiale c'est
à dire à Carré gamma IJ
remplaçons ces deux expressions dans nos
deux équations
ici on va avoir 8 pi0
et voilà la première équation il nous
suffit simplement de remarquer que ce
terme et ce terme sont égaux et donc il
s'annule on va pouvoir réécrire
l'équation juste après pour que ce soit
un peu plus joli et puis en bas TIJ on
le remplace par P
a² gamai ici
là la magie opère on voit qu'on a la
même matrice partout gammaji donc on
peut diviser partout par cette matrice
et alors qu'on avait une équation
matricielle on a maintenant une équation
scalaire on peut diviser également par
a² puisqu'on voit qu'il apparaît assez
souvent
et alors maintenant on va faire un peu
de nettoyage alors tout d'abord les
termes en cas on a deux cas sur a² - 3/4
sur a² donc ça donne - K sur un carré
ensuite les termes en a point point et
bien on a un point point sur a moins 3
points sur a donc ça donne - 2 à points
sur A
et enfin les termes en a point carré on
a plus de à Point Carré sur un carré
moins 3 à Point Carré sur un carré donc
ça me donne moins à Point Carré sur un
carré
et le tout plus lambda
et voilà on a obtenu nos deux équations
alors je vais aller réécrire pour que ce
soit plus beau ici je vais diviser par 3
et on obtient pour la première équation
à Poincaré sur a² + k sur a²
= à 8 P0 plus lambda sur 3 ça c'est la
première équation de Friedman
et puis pour la deuxième équation
on va obtenir ceci est égal à ceci et
donc -
K sur A2 + 2 à points sur a plus à Point
Carré sur un carré moins lambda
est égal à 8 pi GP
et voici les deux équations de Friedman
alors vous voyez qu'on a réussi à
obtenir des équations qui relient le
paramètre d'échelle petit a la dérivée
du paramètre d'échelle donc le rythme
auquel l'univers s'expans et la dérivée
seconde du paramètre d'échelle le rythme
auquel l'expansion accélère et tout ça
on l'a relié au contenu de l'univers
donc à sa densité d'énergie à la
pression du fluide qu'il contient et
puis à la constante cosmologique qui
correspond en fait à ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie sombre un dernier terme qui
compte c'est la courbure de l'espace la
courbure des tranches d'espace donc si
on est dans un espace plat ou dans un
espace courbé avec une courbure positive
ou négative et bien l'expansion de
l'Univers va se comporter différemment
ce qu'on peut faire pour faire une
dernière simplification c'est utiliser
l'équation du dessus pour simplifier un
peu l'équation du dessous en effet vous
voyez qu'on a ici à Poincaré sur un
carré plus k sur un carré c'est
exactement ce qui apparaît ici donc on
peut le remplacer ici si je fais ce
remplacement ça va donner tout ça donc 8
pi G0 + lambda sur 3 + 2 à point point
sur a moins lambda
égale 8 pi GP
là je peux passer le signe moins de
l'autre côté
mon - lambda ici avec le plus lambda sur
3 ça va donner moins de lambda sur trois
ici j'ai un facteur 2 qui est partout
donc je peux diviser toutes l'équation
par deux
je me retrouvais avec 4 piges
ici aussi enfin je peux passer tout ça
de l'autre côté et j'obtiens que à
points sur A est égal à ceci moins ceci
- 4 pigés
facteur de 3P + O + lambda
alors je vais la réécrire ici c'est une
version alternative de la seconde
équation qui est plus utile et elle nous
donne directement la valeur de à point
point le rythme auquel l'expansion
accélère
à pointure a est égal à moins 4 pi G
facteur de 3 p + O
+ lambda
le tout divisé par 3
et voilà les équations de Freedman alors
c'est fini pour la première partie de la
vidéo maintenant on va essayer de
comprendre comment ces équations dictent
le l'évolution de l'univers
alors j'ai recopié les équations de
Freedman ici et on va s'intéresser à
différents scénarios pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'elle nous disent sur
l'expansion de l'Univers
alors la première situation un peu
triviale qui peut nous intéresser c'est
de se demander qu'est-ce qui se passe
lorsque l'Univers est complètement vide
et qu'il n'y a ni énergie sombre donc
pas de constante cosmologique lambda ni
fluide donc pas de densité RAW ou pas de
pression au grand P
et la première équation et bien on peut
multiplier par a² des deux côtés ça nous
donne que a Point Carré plus k va vaut 0
et ça ça nous dit que si cas vaut 0 si
on est dans un espace plat et bien à
point vaut 0 donc l'espace plat ne
s'expan pas il reste à une taille
constante et c'est assez logique si on a
un univers plat et complètement vide et
bien il a aucune raison qu'il change de
taille c'est l'espace de Minkowski et
maintenant si k est négatif et bien dans
ce cas on va avoir que à Point Carré
égal - K c'est à dire la valeur absolue
de cas et donc dans un espace de
courbure négative on va avoir une
expansion à points et non nul mais ceci
ne fixe pas le signe de à point donc on
peut avoir soit à point positif soit à
point négatif
dans tous les cas ce qui compte c'est
que à point est constant puisque à
points vaut 0 donc on a soit un univers
de courbure négative car et négatif qui
s'expans un rythme constant soit qui se
réduit un rythme constant
et on ne peut pas avoir d'univers
complètement vide avec une courbure k
positive puisque cette équation dans ce
cas ne pourrait pas être satisfaite
dans cette situation n'est pas très
intéressante ce qu'on peut étudier
maintenant c'est le cas où grand cas
vaut 0 la courbure est nulle et ce cas
il est plus intéressant puisqu'il
correspond à peu près à notre univers en
tout cas jusqu'à maintenant toutes les
expériences ne détectent aucune courbure
dans l'espace donc on a une très bonne
approximation de notre univers si on
pose que grand cas = 0
alors supprimons la courbure de
l'équation et voyons ce que ça nous
donne on peut commencer par étudier un
univers qui ne contient que la constante
cosmologique donc que de l'énergie
sombre
dans ce cas on aurait à point sur a au
carré qui vaut lambda sur 3 et puis
après sur A qui vaut là aussi lambda sur
alors on peut utiliser la première
équation ici on a que a Point Carré est
égal à lambda sur 3 à carré on sait que
a doit être positif c'est le facteur
d'échelle donc on peut passer à la
racine carrée à droite
par contre à point on ne connaît pas son
signe donc on va mettre une valeur
absolue pour résoudre ça et bien on va
dire tout simplement que a
= à une exponentielle à 0 facteur de
exponentielle de racine de lambda sur 3
T ou t c'est le temps avec ici un signe
plus ou moins en fonction de si on a un
signe plus ou moins ici
donc ce que ça nous dit c'est que le
facteur d'échelle va suivre une
exponentielle ça peut être une
exponentielle croissante au cours du
temps
ou alors ça peut être une exponentielle
décroissante
autrement dit si on a une constante
cosmologique ici qui est positive pour
que la racine carrée soit bien définie
ça veut dire qu'on a de l'énergie sombre
dans notre univers et donc l'expansion
de l'Univers est accélérée alors si
l'univers s'expan et bien s'expans de
plus en plus vite et si au contraire il
se réduit et bien il se réduit de moins
en moins vite
cet univers dans lequel on a aucune
matière et seulement une constante
cosmologique positive c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'espace de Sitter c'est un
assez bon modèle pour décrire un univers
comme le nôtre aujourd'hui qui est
dominé par la constante cosmologique par
l'énergie sombre aujourd'hui l'énergie
sombre correspond à peu près à 75% du
contenu de l'univers
ça c'était pour des univers qui ne
contiennent que de l'énergie sombre et
aucun autre contenu alors maintenant
supprimons l'énergie sombre on a compris
son impact on a compris qu'elle fait
accélérer l'expansion de l'Univers
maintenant intéressant nous à un fluide
et alors il peut y avoir différents
types de fluides en fonction de
l'équation d'état du fluide qui relie la
pression et la densité du fluide alors
on va avoir la poussière par exemple
c'est le genre de fluide le plus simple
on peut imaginer des particules qui ont
une masse qui se déplace mais qui n'ont
aucune pression qui ne se voit pas les
unes avec les autres donc la poussière
c'est définie par P = 0 aucune pression
la matière sombre par exemple la matière
noire c'est une forme de poussière on la
décrit comme de la poussière ensuite on
peut imaginer un univers qui contiennent
du rayonnement des photons de la lumière
par exemple
pour le rayonnement on va avoir de la
pression la pression de rayonnement la
pression est égale à la densité divisée
par 3 et puis enfin on peut avoir un
fluide quelconque donc général qui va
généraliser les deux situations d'avant
fluide parfait avec la relation P
= une certaine constante qu'on va noter
Kappa fois la densité RAW donc vous
voyez que la poussière c'est pour Kappa
= 0 et puis le rayonnement c'est pour
Kappa égale un tiers
alors essayons de faire le calcul pour
le fluide quelconque dans ce cas on a
que a point carré sur a²
= 8 pi G0 sur 3
ça c'est notre première équation la
deuxième équation c'est que à point
point sur A est égal à -4 piges 3 p
alors P c'est Caparo donc on va voir
trois Kappa plus un facteur de RAW sur 3
alors ici c'est génial puisque on peut
exprimero en fonction uniquement du
facteur d'échelle on a que 4 piges 0 si
je divise par 2
sur 3 est égal à Point Carré sur deux à
Carré donc ça ça vient directement de
l'équation d'eau dessus
et donc ici j'ai quatre piges héros sur
3 donc je peux le remplacer par ça et ça
me donne que à point point sur A est
égal à moins trois cas plus un sur deux
facteurs de a point carré sur
à ce stade on peut se rendre compte
qu'on va avoir sûrement besoin du
logarithme de a puisqu'on a des dérivés
qui sont à dimensionnés à Poincaré sur
a² à points sur a donc on va poser que a
= à l'exponentielle d'une certaine
fonction f du temps
alors dans ce cas à point et bien ça va
être F point x a
et à point point ça va être F point
point
fois a plus f.a carré
fois
donc après sur A et bien ça va faire
F point + F Point Carré
est égal à - 3 Kappa + 1 sur 2 facteur
de a point carré sur un carré donc ça
fait F Point Carré
si je passe ça de l'autre côté
j'obtiens 1 - 1 là dedans donc je peux
en fait remplacer ce plus un par un + 3
maintenant je vais diviser des deux
côtés par - f-2 donc j'obtiens - F point
sur f.c
et ici si vous regardez bien vous avez
la dérivée de 1 sur F point
puisque la dérivée de 1 sur f. ça va
donner -1 sur f.a carré fois la dérivée
de F1 fois F point point donc ici en
intégrant on obtient un sur F1 et en
intégrant ça bien on va obtenir trois
cas pas plus un sur deux fois le temps t
plus une constante mais on peut
directement l'intégrer autant t en
fonction de l'origine qu'on choisit
maintenant si je prends la verse
j'obtiens que F point
est égal à 2 sur 3 cas pas plus un T
et ici encore une fois en intégrant
j'obtiens que F de T est égal vous voyez
qu'on a un logarithme donc j'ai deux sur
trois cas pas plus simple
logarithme du temps t puisqu'on a la
dérivée qui est 1 sur T
encore une fois on peut avoir une
constante mais en fait la constante ça
va simplement revenir à multiplier a par
une constante ici et en fonction des
unités qu'on choisit on peut supprimer
cette constante et bien on a presque
fini maintenant il suffit de prendre F
et de le mettre dans l'exponentielle
pour trouver l'expression de a et on
obtient que a de T est égal alors
exponentielle de log t ça donne t et
puis on a cette puissance là qui vient
dans l'exponentielle donc ça fait t à la
puissance 2 sur 3 CAPA plus un
ça c'est l'évolution du facteur
d'échelle de la taille de l'univers en
fonction du temps pour un fluide qui
obéit à l'équation d'état p =
alors plus précisément comme je l'ai dit
on peut dire que ceci est proportionnel
et puis sinon on peut mettre une
constante à zéro puisque en fait
l'échelle peut être changer en fonction
du choix d'unité
bon alors regardons ce que ça donne pour
les deux cas précis qu'on a vu pour de
la poussière on a qu'à pas qu'il vaut 0
donc ici on a deux sur trois et donc
pour de la poussière on aura
un facteur d'échelle
en fonction de T à la puissance 2/3
maintenant pour du rayonnement on a Kapa
qui vaut un tiers donc ici on a un tiers
plus 1 ça donne 4/3 ici le 4/3 X 3 donne
4 et donc 2 sur 4 donne 1/2 donc pour du
rayonnement
on obtient que le facteur d'échelle est
proportionnel à T puissance 1/2
c'est-à-dire à la racine carrée de T
et puis enfin comme on l'a vu pour de
l'énergie sombre
le facteur d'échelle est proportionnel à
l'exponentielle de la racine carrée de
lambda sur 3 fois le temps donc c'est
une exponentielle alors si on résume
tout ça on peut reformer l'évolution de
l'Univers au cours du temps lorsqu'il
était très jeune l'univers était
principalement dominé par du rayonnement
il contenait beaucoup de rayonnements
donc à partir du Big Bang on a une forme
qui est de ce type là qui ressemble à
une racine carrée
ensuite à partir d'un moment
l'univers était suffisamment peu dense
pour que la matière devienne dominante
donc cette fois-ci on avait t à la
puissance 2/3
et puis au bout d'un certain temps
l'univers est tellement dilué que
l'énergie sombre a pris le dessus et on
est entré dans une phase en expansion
accélérée exponentielle donc ici vous
pouvez voir qu'on a réussi à retrouver
l'évolution du facteur d'échelle au
cours du temps et on a en particulier
retrouvé l'instant du Big Bang qui est
cet instant à partir duquel on ne sait
pas trop décrire l'expansion de
l'Univers peut-être que l'Univers était
très dense et qu'il a suivi une phase
d'expansion accélérée c'est aujourd'hui
la théorie la plus admise c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'inflation et donc il y aurait
eu une autre phase d'expansion
exponentielle avant la phase dominée par
le rayonnement